c'est à la mairie de saint-andré que les
acteurs de la filière plantes à parfum
et plantes médicinales se sont retrouvés
afin de se donner une nouvelle dynamique
une convention avec un leader du
cosmétique c'est une vitrine mondiale de
la biodiversité et des plantes
cosmétiques
si vous avez un trésor volé ses cachets
et ou mettez pas en valeur vous
produisez pas de richesses et donc pas
d'emploi pas d'exportation au nous
sommes condamnés à produire et exporter
la cosmetic valley promet ainsi un
développement de cette filière dynamique
fruit de notre tradition et de notre
biodiversité
pour cela un plan d'action collectif est
en projet mais surtout le moyen devrait
développer de nouveaux produits
il est d'être présent sur un marché qui
en fait déjà un moment et la cosmétique
contrairement à bouhrouz marché est un
marché qui se développe entre 4 et 7%
par an dans le mois et ses marchés comme
n24 orateurs
milliard d'euros donc et avec
développement vision très très fort les
échanges avec la salle montre cette
volonté de voir loin mais ensemble et si
cette convention est signée dans l'est
la vision du territoire et globale de
ckoi étudier ce projet prendra une
dimension départementale
tout simplement parce que nous avons un
projet bien soin de remettre en valeur
les terres agricoles en friche nous
irons d'été et nous identifions des
opérateurs ben dhiab longtemps que tu es
soit nano est bien saisir bas ne peut
pas vendre la nasa aujourd'hui on veut
passer un nouvel un nouveau stade en
travaillant avec les agriculteurs à
structurer les filières de façon à
ouvrir ses plans finale vers le marché
réunionnais mais surtout vers le marché
mondial le grand grand enjeu c'est à
dire de non seulement répondre à une
demande croissante
un engouement pour les plantes qui va
aller de façon exponentielle mais aussi
en respectant la ressource qui elle suit
à la vitesse de la nature c'est à dire
que si on veut respecter la demande il
faut que l'on puisse ne pas piller ne
pas cueillir en forêt connaître les
plantes qu'ils sont
cultivé et aujourd'hui non seulement ça
donnera du travail à des producteurs
agricoles mais aussi permettra à des
gens d'en vivre et pour venir comprendre
concrètement le potentiel de
développement de ces papam
rendez vous samedi 16 mars au coeur de
la nature de dioré
[Musique]